[موسيقى]
طاب مساؤكم واهلا بكم الى التاسعه هذا
المساء وهذه عناوينها
والتزامهما بالهدنه واشنطن تعاقب شركه
تابعه للجيش السوداني ودعم السريع وتلوح
بالمزيد
زعيمه صربيا وكوسوفو يساعدان الازمه بين
بلديهما وتحرك غربي لمنع الحرب بينهما
لاول مره منذ الحرب الاوكرانيه روسيا تصده
هجوما بالدبابات على الحدوديه
للوراء ويعتزمان التوقف عن انتقاد العائله
المالكه عبر الاعلام
[موسيقى]
وفي تفاصيل التاسعه هذا المساء
طفح الكيل وحان موعد العقاب هذا ما بدا
عليه المسؤولون في الاداره الامريكيه في
التعامل مع عدم التزام بهدنه وقف اطلاق
نار بالسودان عقوبات هي الاولى من نوعها
منذ نظام عمر البشير البيت الابيض اعلن
فرض عقوبات اقتصاديه جديده وقيود على
التاشيرات بحق الاطراف الذين يمارسون
العنف في السودان في اشاره الى الجيش ودعم
السريع عقوبات جاءت بعد ساعات من انسحاب
الجيش من المفاوضات مع الدعم تلا ذلك
الانسحاب تجدد للشبكات في مناطق عده
بالعاصمه الخرطوم ما توجب تدخلا امريكيا
كما يقول مستشار البيت الابيض
عرض امريكي باستئناف جهود وقف النار في
السودان بيد انه مرهون بجديه الطرفي
النزاع في الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار كشرط
اساسي وفق ما اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه واشنطن اعربت عن اسافها من قرار
الجيش السوداني وقف المحادثات معتبره ان
الخطوه تصاعب وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
الى السودانيين
انه امر مؤسف انسحاب احد اطراف الصراع في
السودان اذ نريد ان يتوقف القتال وان تصل
المساعدات الى المدنيين فمن الصعب عليها
الان ان تصل الى من هم في امس الحاجه
اليها كالغذاء والماء والدواء لذلك من
المؤسف للغايه انهم اختاروا تعليق
المحادثات نريدهم ان يختنموا فرصه السلام
على محمل الجد ونحن بالتاكيد جدون في
المساعده وفي تسهيل هذه المحادثات
الخطوه جاءت بعد تبادل الاتهامات بين
الطرفين بخرق الهدنه الجيش من جانبه اوضح
ان تعليق مشاركته في محادثات جده مع الدعم
السريع برعايه سعوديه امريكيه بسبب عدم
التزام قوات الدعم السريع ببنود الهدنه
واتهمها بالفشل في الايفاء بالتزاماتها
كما راى انه لا معنى للاستمرار في تمديد
الهدنه في ظل الخروق التي ترتكبها قوات
الدعم السريع
اما قوات الدعم السريع فقد اكدت التزامها
بالمفاوضات مشيره الى ان الجيش تعمد تعطيل
الهدنه
على الارض دوي اطلاق النار لا يتوقف في
مناطق متفرقه بالخرطوم والولايات
والوضع الانساني يمضي من سيء الى اسوا
تهدد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه هدد باتخاذ
مزيد من الاجراءات ضد قاده الصراع في
السودان اذا لم يلتزم بالهدنه والوصول الى
تهدئه حقيقيه واصفا وقفت لقي في السودان
بانه هش للغايه
سودان
في السودان وقف اطلاق النار هاشون للغايه
هناك مخاطر كبيره تحيط بالسودانيين
ومازلنا بعيدين جدا عن التوصل لهدنه
حقيقيه وهذا ليس من مصلحه احد هذا العنف
يجب ان يتوقف ونحن نراقب ونعرف ان الطرفي
الصراع انتهك التزاماتهما وهذا لا يجب ان
يمضي بدون حساب ننظر في خطوات يمكننا
اتخاذها لتوضيح وجهات نظرنا حيال اي زعماء
يقودون السودان في الاتجاه الخاطئ
نذهب الان الى واشنطن ومعلم هناك بير غانم
مراسل العربيه بير مرحبا بك معنا في
التاسعه هذا المساء ما الهدف من العقوبات
الامريكيه الان على شركات تتبع لطرفي
الصراع في السودان
الهدف المحدد هو منع وصول الذخيره والسلاح
الى هذين الطرفين وهذا ما قاله مسؤول كبير
في البيت الابيض خلال ايجاز مع الصحفيين
الهدف الثاني هو محاوله افهام الطرفين على
ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه جاده في
الضغط عليهما وعليهما ان يلتزما بوقف
اطلاق النار والتقدم باتجاه حل دائم
وتسليم السلطه الى المدنيين
وسط تلوح بالمزيد من العقوبات مثل ماذا
ماذا نفهم
حتى الان ليس واضح ممكن ان تكون عليه
الخطوه التاليه بالنسبه للامريكيين ولكن
بحسب ما راينا من العقوبات التي فرضت
اليوم من وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه وايضا
من قبل وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه هناك
الجزء الاول وهو الجزء الاقتصادي والهدف
منه هو الضغط على الطرفين ومنعهما من
الوصول الى المال والسلاح الجزء الثاني
وهو سياسي ما نراه في العقوبات التي صدرت
عن وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه قالوا ان
هناك عدد كبير من المسؤولين في السودان
الذين سوف يحرمون من الفيزا للدخول الى
اراضي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وبالتالي من الممكن تصعيد هذه الامور
صعودا ولكن لا يبدو انها سوف تصل الى
البرهان وحمنتي طيب يعني هل تاخذ الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بعين الاعتبار هذه
العقوبات والجهود لدفع طرفي الصراع من
خلال ممثلي هم للتفاوض من اجل هدنه طويله
الامد
انهم يحاولون الكثير وقد قالوا انهم
يعملون بشكل لصق مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لافهام الطرفين انه يجب التوجه
باتجاه واحد وهو وقف اطلاق النار وتسليم
السلطه يبدو ان الامريكيين يستعملون لهجه
قاسيه الى حد كبير جدا يحاولون استعمال
ايضا ما بجعبتهم من وسائل الضغط الاقتصادي
والسياسي على امل ان يصلوا الى نتيجه ولكن
تشعرين في الوقت ذاته ان الامريكيين لا
يرون ان هناك ثمار واضحه لجهودهم ويريدون
ان يروا هذه الجهود باقرب وقت ممكن شكرا
جزيلا لك من واشنطن مراسل العربيه
[موسيقى]
حرب جديده في افق البلقان قلق يشغل بال
دول الغرب لتخرج مناشدات اوروبيه ومعها
مساء امريكيه للاطراف المتصارعه الشمال
كوسوفو لتجنب التصعيد بين الالبان والصرب
هناك تجنب يعتبره الغرب لا داعي له الان
في اشاره فسرت بان الغرب لن يتحمل جبهه
اخرى تشغلها عن الحرب في اوكرانيا النبره
الغربيه كانت تحذيريه لكلا الطرفين لكنها
سبقتها بخطوه على الارض وهي رفع الوجود
العسكري للنيتو في كوسوفو والتي بدورها
اعتبرت الازمه شانا داخليا متهمه الجاره
الصربيه بافتعال هذه الفتنه جاء ذلك على
لسان رئيستها على هامش مشاركته في القمه
الاوروبيه في ما اشترط رئيس صربيا سحب من
وصفهم برؤساء البلديات المزعومين من مناطق
الصرب شمال كوسوفو لحل الاسماء
[موسيقى]
هذا وواصل متظاهرون صرب احتجاجاتهم في
شمال كوسوفو رفضا لتسلم رؤساء بلديات
البان مناصبهم جاء ذلك فيما شهدت كوسوفو
على مدار الايام الماضيه مواجهات مع قوه
حفظ السلام التابعه لحلف شمال الاطلسي
فيما يتصاعد الضغط الدولي على البلدين
لوقف تصاعد التوتر
الصراع بين الصرب والالبان ليس بجديد فهو
جزء من الخلاف حول وضع كسوف والحالي والتي
اعلنت استقلالها قبل 15 عاما كوسوفو
سكانها من اصل البني وكانت في السابق
مقاطعه من صربيا قبل اعلان استقلالها عام
2008 رفضت صربيا الاعتراف بدوله كوسوفو
وما زالت تعتبرها جزءا من صربيا على رغم
من عدم وجود سيطره رسميه عليها فيما تنظر
الاكثريه الالبانيه الموجوده في كوسوفو
الى نيكوسوفو هي بلدهم ويتهمون صربيا
بالاحتلال والقمع يتطلع البان كوسوفو
مستقبلا الى الاتحاد مع البانيا المجاوره
ضمن دوله البانيا الكبرى تعترف نحو 100
دوله باستقلال كوسوفو بما في ذلك الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بينما ان حازت روسيا
والصين وخمس دول من الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
صربيا بالحديث عن هذه الازمه تلقى المصنف
الاول عالميا في التنس نوفاك جوكوفيتش
ردود فعل غاضبه جراء اتخاذه موق سياسيا
وابرازه خلال بطوله في فرنسا كتب جوكوفيتش
على احدى عدسات الكاميرا لبطوله التنس
المقامه في باريس كتبا كوسوفو قلب صربيا
اوقف العنف الا ان النجمه الصربي قال انه
يدرك ان الناس سيختلفون معه في الرساله
السياسيه التي كتبها على عدسات الكاميرا
لكنها قضيه يؤيدها كما قال
مشهد التوتر المحتدم بين الكوسوفو وصربيا
يتصاعد يوما بعد يوم لتصبح زاويه تبادل
الاتهامات بين رؤساء البلدين سيده الموقف
وتغطي على معارك الميدان التي لم تسفر عن
اصابات اليوم
فعلى ما يبدو صربيا لا تزال تنكر سياده
كوسوفو بحسب تصريحات رئيساتها فويس عثماني
التي اتهمت نظيرها الصربي بتقديم الدعم
لجماعات مسلحه واشعال فتيل الفتنه شمالي
البلاد
السبب هو دعم رئيس صربيا الكساندر فوتشيتش
سياسيا وماليا هياكل غير قانونيه تحولت
الى عصابات اجراميه هي جماعات الجريمه
المنظمه العابره للحدود وهي مجموعات خطيره
للغايه تسببت ايضا في العنف ضد جنود
النيتو
الرئيس الصربي الكسندر فوتوش راما كره
الجليد في ملعب نظيرته لاخماد الاشتباك
الدائر عبر التراجع عن القرار المتعلق
برؤساء البلديات الالبان ليرد على
اتهاماتها باستعداده اقناع شعبه بالاحتجاج
بهدوء في وقت دفع بتعزيزات عسكريه لجيشه
على الحدود
انهم مصممون وحاسمون للغايه اعتقد ان
الخطوه التي قد تحل المشاكل هي انسحاب
رؤساء البلديات المزعومين
تخوفات اوروبيه من مشهد التصعيد بين
البلدين وصدعوات الى نزعفه للتوتر على
الفور ودون قيد او شرط فالخلاف القائم
قديم جديد عمره عقدان من الزمن لكنه قد
ينذر بتفجير محتمل في اوروبا
نذهب الى ضيفي التاسعه هذا المساء
الكريمين من بريستينا دكتور محمد كاليسي
الاستاذ في الاعلام والباحث في شؤون
البلقان ومن بلغراد الدكتور داركوت تريفو
مدير المعهد الوطني للامن الدولي اهلا بكم
معنا في التاسعه هذا المساء دكتور محمد
ابدا معك صراع قديم ولكن توقيت هذا الصراع
هل هو بريء بين صربيا
يبدو ان حاليا داخل صربيا هناك
للرئيس الحالي مشاكل الداخليه كما راينا
تقريبا قبل اسبوع كانت هناك مظاهرات حاشده
ضد السياسات الداخليه للرئيس السلبي
هذا الرئيس السلبي
هو كان من الشخصيات
المتطرفه
البارزه حتى اثناء العهد الرئيس السربي
السابق الذي حكم بجرائم الحرب في وهو
الرئيس كلا
كان وزيرا للاعلام في تلك الحكومه
فنزعته وافكاره
المتطرفه القوميه السلبيه هي ما زالت
موجوده فكل ما الرئيس السربي او الحكومه
السلبيه تواجه مشاكل في الداخل فهي تحاول
تفتعل المشاكل خارج الحدود لكي يتم تهدئه
الوضع هنا
كذلك طيب خلينا انقل هذه النقطه خليني
انقل هذه النقطه لدكتور داركو دكتور داركو
هل اليوم صربيا حاولت افتعال هذه الازمه
تعلمنا في كوسوفو وحاولت ايضا حشد الصرب
الموجودون هناك مع انها
انتخابات هنا
قبل كل شيء تحياتي الى البروفيسور محمد
كليسي والى كافه مشاهديكم مشاهديكم الكرام
ردا على السؤال كل شيء ممكن
فكلما تكون هناك مشاكل داخليه ما الذي
تفعلونه تسعون لتصدير هذه المشاكل من اجل
خلق مساله ما لكن في هذه الحاله على وجه
التحديد لابد لنا ان نقنع وان نطلع
المشاهدين ان هؤلاء العمد الذين تم
تعيينهم في شمال كوسوفو يشكلنا واحد في
المئه من نسبه السكان
99% من السكان هم من الصرب
ولم يذهبوا للانتخابات فقط نسبه واحد في
المئه التي شاركت في هذه الانتخابات لان
الصرف قاطعوا تلك الانتخابات اذا كيف يمكن
لنسبه واحده في المئه من السكان ان تمثلك
هذه البلديات كليه هذه
لا بد لكم ان تتفهموها بصوره اساسيه دكتور
محمد دكتور
محمد
من السكان ان تحكم فيما يتعلق بها
الانتخابات يعني هذه النقطه التي اشار
اليها دكتور
للاسف شديد
الاقليه السلبيه التي تعيش في هذه المناطق
مناطق الشماليه من كوستا هي اداه سياسيه
واداه الضغط على كوسوفي
بايدي الرئيس الصربي لدينا في كوسفه عشره
بلديات هناك في شمال الكوسوفا لدينا قريبه
هناك بلديه
قريبه من العاصمه ليس هناك اي مشاكل
وهم الصرب الذين يحكمون شؤونهم شؤونهم
المحليه في هذه المحافظه كذلك في برزوميتا
وكذلك في عده مدن اخرى ذات او بلديات ذات
اغلبيه صربيه ليست هناك اي مشاكل لكن
من فعل هذه المشكله هناك مجموعه جاءت من
داخل صربيا من الصربيا هل تعتقد بان
الصربيا اليوم تريد فعلا حرب مفتوحه مع
كوسوفو حرب على غرار ما نراه مثلا بين
روسيا واوكرانيا الان
لا يمكن صربيا ان تقوم بحرب صربيا في موقف
ضعيف صربيا محاصره بكل الدول حلف الناتو
صربيا هي تريد فقط ربما تستغل قضيه اخرى
لكي تكسب او هناك في جبل الاسود في
البوسنه وفي الدول المجاوره من خلال
افتيار هذه الازمات هي السلبيات دائما
تكون مستفيده ودائما تكسب تكسب تنازلات من
قبل الدول الغربيه والولايات المتحده
في تلك البلديات كانوا حكومات او الرؤساء
بلديات محليين الصرب لكن السرب قاطعه اول
انتخابات نحن اجلنا او الحكومه الكسوفيه
اجلت الانتخابات
ودكتور داركو يعني يقول دكتور محمد انه
الصين بقاطعه انا سؤالي لك لو لم يقاطع
الصرب انتخابات المجالس المحليه لما سمح
للالبان بالسيطره عليها كيف ترد
الانتخابات لان الجانب الالباني لم يحترم
هذا
اتفاقيه السلم في فلسطين التي تملي بوجود
بوجود مجتمع
يحتوي على بلديات يراسها مجموعه من الصرب
لكنهم قد التزموا بالوفاء بواجباتهم
الدوليه التي تملي بخلق بلديات
الصربيه في السنوات العشر الماضيه تم رفض
هذا المقترح
خصوصا في هذه الاحتفالات في قصر زهران كان
ايضا وصول الاحتفالات ووصول العرسان الى
الحسينيه حيث استقبل الوفود وايضا
الحاضرين لمشاركتهما هذه الفرحه طبعا
نتابع معكم هذه المشاهد اليوم هو عرس عرس
وطني في كافه ارجاء المملكه الاردنيه
الهاشميه الجميع يحتفل بولي العهد وبعقد
قرانه على الاميره رجوى السيف الاميره
السعوديه اليوم هذه اصبحت اميره بعد ان
عقدت زفافها وقرانها على الامير الحسين بن
عبد الله متابع معكم هذه المشاهد طبعا كنا
تابعنا ايضا وخلينا نستمع صوت الطبيعه ومن
ثم نعود
[موسيقى]
ما زالت هذه الاغاني الاردنيه
والاهازيج والزغاريد تطغى في المملكه
الاردنيه الهاشميه وفي هذه الاحتفالات
التي حضرها الالاف نتحدث عن اكثر من 4000
مدعو جاءوا
ليتابع ويشاركوا هذه الفرحه الفرحه ليست
فرحه اردنيه بل هي فرحه اردنيه وفرحه
سعوديه لان
الانسه رجوى الشيخ هي سعوديه والان اصبحت
الاميره رجوى الحسين
[موسيقى]
اذا كنا نتابع معكم منذ ساعات الصباح
الباكر حيث استقبل الملك عبد الله الثاني
وايضا الملكه رانيا كل الحضور منذ ساعات
الصباح الباكر ومن ثمها من ثم بعدها تم
عقد القران بحضور ايضا عدد كبير من الملوك
والقاده والامراء للدول والاحتفالات ما
زالت مستمره سواء في قصر الحسينيه وايضا
قصر زهران وحتى في شوارع المملكه الاردنيه
الهاشميه هذه هي المشاهد مباشره على كل
حال نعود الى ضيفي الكريمين الى بريشنا
دكتور محمد كنيسه وايضا الى دكتور داركوب
اذا نعود اليك دكتور محمد حتى نفهم الصوره
اليوم هل يمكن ان تتصور الازمه الى حرب
الى ابعد من ذلك
اعتقد ان من خلال الاتصالات المستمره هذه
الايام الاخيره خاصه ثلاثه ايام الاخيره
هناك
يبدو ان الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي وكذلك
الولاده المتحده تحاول ويعملون جاهدون
لتهدئه الاوضاع وحتى اليوم
سمعنا من رئيس الفرنسي امام المقرون وكذلك
المستشار الالماني انهم اقترحوا ان تجرى
انتخابات جديده في هذه الاربع البلديات
وحسب فهمي للاوضاع هناك وتحليل الاوضاع
كذلك يبدو ان الحكومه او تبدو ان الحكومه
الكوسفيه كذلك هي راغبه في ايجاد سلمي
الجميل حقوق لجميع الجهات الموجوده هنا
سواء
ماذا عنك دكتور داركو هل فعلا تلمس صربيا
اشارات سلميه من الجانب كوسوفو فيما يتعلق
بالوصول الى حل ولملمه هذه الازمه
تدركون بان هناك محادثات السلم تتم الان
تحت مظله الاتحاد الاوروبي وجزء من
الاتفاق انه يجب ان يتم خلق مجتمعا من
الجاليه صربيا السيد كورتي واصدقائه
وزملائه رفضوا وفعل ذلك ورفضوا الالتزامات
الدوليه
وهذا جوهر الخلاف فضلا عن ذلك من على
الصعيد السياسي
فانتم تقومون بارسال قوات خاصه لا يمكن
فعل ذلك اذا كنتم ملتزمون بالسلم اذا كنتم
ملتزمون بالسلم فعليكم ان تلتزموا
بمحادثات السلم واحترام القوانين الدوليه
والقواعد الدوليه ولابد لي ان اذكركم هنا
ان كوسوفو هي ليست دوله مستقله وليست دوله
عضو في الامم المتحده ولن تصبح كذلك ولن
تحصل على اي نوع من الاستقلال الى حين
اعتمادها بصوره كامله من قبل الامم
المتحده تعلمون ان تعريف الدوله
ينص على انها يجب ان تكون دوله عضو من
الامم المتحده والا سوف تبقى بمجرد اقليم
نعلم ان ان صرب قد ترغب باجراء هذه
المحادثات من كافه الادوات وليس ليكون
مجرد اداه جيو سياسيه
واشكرك جزيل الشكر من الدكتور داركو تراب
نوفيتش مدير المعهد الوطني للامن الدولي
ونشكر ايضا دكتور محمد كليس الاستاذ في
الاعلام والباحث في شؤون البلقان شكرا لكم
تاسعه هذا المساء مستمره ونتابع في سياقها
ولكن بعد قليل
لدعمها ضد روسيا قادت اوروبا يجتمعون في
مولدوفا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في التاسعه هذا المساء محاوله
غزو اوكرانيه بالدبابات تعرضت لها بالقرود
الروسيه لكن القوات الروسيه افشلتها هذا
ما اعلنت عنه موسكو التي قالت انها تصدت
بسلاحها الجوي ومدفعيتها عبور مجموعات
اوكرانيه
مكونه من سريتين من المشاه معززتين
بدبابات لغزو الاراضي روسيه الهجوم
الاوكراني لم يتوقف هنا فالمنطقه الروسيه
الحدوديه تتعرض لقصف مدفعيا وصاروخيه
مستمر من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه وفقا
لحاكم منطقتي
[موسيقى]
بالقرود او المدينه البيضاء لكثره جبال
الطباشير فيها على راس قائمه الاستهدافات
الاوكرانيه في الداخل الروسي مدينه ضمن
سكانها انهم محايدون لكن العمليه العسكريه
التي شنتها روسيا في اوكرانيا لم تبقى
داخل حدود الاخيره بل امتدت اليها بالقرود
تقع جنوب غربي روسيا على بعد حوالي 500 كم
من العاصمه الروسيه موسكو واربعين كيلو
مترا الى شمال الحدود مع اوكرانيا حدودها
تمتد على طول
الف150 كيلو مترا منها 450 كيلومترا مع
اوكرانيا وحدها تشمل هذه الحدود مناطق
لوجانسك وخركيف وسومي في الشمال والشمال
الغربي وكرسك شرقا تحتل مقاطعه بيل قرود
اهميه عسكريه لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه حيث
شكلت معبرا لامدادات قواتها وتحركها نحو
لوغانسك وايضا ازيوم عند هذه النقاط كما
نتابع معكم كمان اهميتها تنبع من قربها
ايضا من خركيز التي تبعد عنها 71 كيلومترا
فقط الهجمات الاوكرانيه المتتاليه وفق
مراقبين لبست هيئه رسائل عسكريه تريد كيف
ايصالها لموسكو عن قدرتها بضرب العمق
الروسي حينما ارادت
اذا بالمسيرات والهجمات الصاروخيه ضربت
القوات الاوكرانيه بوتا في عقر داره سوافي
بالقرود او العاصمه مؤخرا غير نابوتين صمت
بشكل غير معتاد لا بل ان عدم اكتراثه ظهر
وكان شيئا لم يحدث هذا السلوك اي التظاهر
بعدم الانزعاج فسرته صحيفه واشنطن بولس
على انه محاوله لاظهار الاحساس بالهدوء
والسيطره فيما وصفه محللون بمحاوله لمنع
تملمه للذعر بين شعبه وصرف الانتباه نقاط
الضعف في دفاعات روسيا فرئيس روسي اكتفى
بالاشاره الى عمل نظام الدفاع الجوي بشكل
جيد متهما كيف بالترهيب والاستفزاز
سياسيون وصقور مؤيدون للحرب انتقدوا فشل
موسكو في منع طائرات بدون طيار من دخول
المجال الجوي للعاصمه مطالبين اياها برد
اشد قسوه كما تقول الصحيفه الامريكيه اما
رئيس مجموعه فاغنر هو الاخر استغرب ما
يحصل متسائلا عن سبب السماح لهذه المسيرات
بالتحليق الى موسكو فيما دعى بيترتل سوي
نائب رئيس مجلس الدوما البرلمان الروسي لا
احتلال كيف وذهبت بعض التوقعات الى وجود
خطط لتطبيق الاحكام العرفيه لكن المتحدث
باسم
نفى اي مناقشات بهذا الخصوص شاكيا عدم
انتقاد الغرب للهجوم
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى بالقرود ومعنا من هناك عبد
الجواد الرشد مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد
اهلا بك معنا في التاسعه هذا المساء اين
تركز القصف بالغرود اليوم
[موسيقى]
مساء الخير ناديا نعم بالفعل يعني حتى
مدينه بيلجرد الهادئه خلال الاسبوع الاخير
طلقت اليوم ضربات بمسييرتين الاولى قامت
اجهزه الدفاع الجوي باسقاطها والثانيه
سقطت في شارع كنا شاهدناه واياك في
النشرات سابقه ايضا سمعت ضربات لاجهزه
الدفاع الجوي في اصطياد الصاروخ على
الارجح حسب الانباء الوارده من هناك كان
على مشارف المدينه طبعا مدينه شيبكينا
والتقارير الوارده من هناك منذ ساعات
الصباح الباكر تنال حصه الاسد من الضربات
الاوكرانيه خرج حاكم بيل قبل نحو ثلاث
ساعات وتحدث عن ان عدد الضربات التي نفذها
الجانب الاوكراني خلال الساعات الاربع
والعشرين الماضيه وصل عددها الى 290 ضربه
طالت معظمها مدينه شيبكن التي تلقت وحدها
2005 عشره الضربه بالمناسبه نادين يعني
عمليه النزوحيه مستمره حتى اللحظه الى
المدينه ملجئين من اصل ثمانيه قامت او
اماكن مؤقته لاستقبال اللاجئين امتلاا
بشكل كامل العدد يقترب من
1500 شخص في كل يعني في المكانين بينما
تستقبل باقي الاماكن المؤقته لاستقبال
اللاجئين في مركز المدينه القادمين من تلك
المناطق ما زال باقي بقيه السكان
الجالسين الان في شبكنا يتلقون الرسائل
التحذيريه بضروره اخذ الحيطه ونزول الى
مباني او يعني اماكن الحمايه او الملاجئ
امام هذه المعطيات عبد الجواد هل نحن امام
دومباس جديده
نعم هذا ما يدور الحديث عنه قد تصبح هذه
المنطقه
حقيقيه من جديد باعتبار ان الجانب
الاوكراني من طرف
لديه من المعدات العسكريه ما يكفي للوقوف
ويعني الوقوف كند امام الجانب الروسي
بالرغم من المحاولات الفاشله للدخول
للاراضي الروسيه التي تحدث اليوم للمره
السادسه الا ان خارجه فيها مليئه بالاسلحه
حسب القراءه العسكريه للداخل الروسي
والخارج وهذا ما قد يحول هذا الاقليم
لمنطقه قد تستمر فيها العمليات العسكريه
لسنوات طويله شكرا جزيلا لك من عبد الجواد
الرشد مراسل العربيه
نماذج الحرب السائده وانماطها التقليديه
تتغير بتقادم السنين مع تطور تكنولوجيات
كل عصر حرب اوكرانيا قد تتحول ارض اختبارا
لذكاء الصناعي الذي يشهد فورة غير
اعتياديه لكن كيف قد يؤثر في فصولها فذكاء
الصناعي يحد اولا من ازهاق الارواح من دون
قصد مع امكانيه تقديمه معلومات استراتيجيه
تفصيليه للغايه عن الاستهداف الاستخدام
المفترض لذكاء الاصطناعي في توجيه
المسيرات واستخدام الاسلحه الدقيقه يتيح
الكييف زياده استنزاف امتدادات روسيا
المتضائله من المدرعات ودفع قواتها لفقدان
صواريخ دفاع جوي مهمه كما يشكل اداه قويه
في الحرب النفسيه والمعلوماتيه مع امكانيه
تزييف فيديوهات تتسبب بردود فعل خاطئه من
جانب قوات العدو وتزيد شعورهم بالفشل كما
ذكرت واشنطن بوست الافاده تمتد كذلك الى
الانشطه الدفاعيه في الحرب ضرب لوجيسيات
الخصم التي تعد نقطه ضعف للجيوش اما
الهجمات المضاده فاخطر سمات الذكاء
الاصطناعي اي القدره على اقتحام الشبكات
الالكترونيه للعدو
[موسيقى]
اكد لمين العام لحلف شمال الاطلس يانس ان
باب النيت لا يزال مفتوحا ان جميع اعضاء
الحلف يتفقون على ان اوكرانيا ستكونوا
عضوا فيها
يتفق جميع الحلفاء على ان باب النيتو لا
يزال مفتوحا وان اتخاذ القرارات بشان
العضويه فقط للحلفاء واوكرانيا روسيا ليس
لديها حق الفيتو ويتفق جميع الحلفاء على
ان اوكرانيا ستصبح عضوا في النيتو ونتفق
جميعا على ان اهم شيء الان هو ان تكون
اوكرانيا دوله مستقله وذات سياده
القرب من اوكرانيا حيث اجتمع نحو 50
الاجتماع تم في قريه بولكا والقريبه من
منطقه انفصاليه مواليه لروسيا ويحمل
اختيار موقع الاجتماع رساله الى موسكو هي
انولدوفا ليست وحدها
قدروا اوروبا مواجهه روسيا ليس في
اوكرانيا فحسب بل في مناطق توتر مختلفه
القاره العجوز تجتمع في مولدوفا للوقوف في
وجه موسكو الدوله الصغيره الشاهده عن قرب
على العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
المجاوره تعيش في خوف مستمر من احتمال
زعزعه استقرارها رساله المجتمعين لموسكو
عنوانها ليست وحدها
مولدوفا وضعها مشابه لاوكرانيا فهي تضم
جيبا انفصاليا الامر يتعلق بترانسنيستريال
المنطقه الانفصاليه المواليه لروسيا التي
يبلغ عدد سكانها 300 الف نسمه شرقيه
البلاد وعاصمتها تيراسبول توجد على الشريط
الضيق بين نهر دينيسترو والحدود
الاوكرانيه ومعترف بها دوليا في الوقت
الحالي كجزء من مولدوفا
بعد حل الاتحاد السوفيتي تصاعد التوتر بين
مولدوفا واراضي ترانسني الانفصاليه الى
صراع عسكري بدا في مارس من العام
1992 وانتهى بوقف اطلاق النار في يوليو من
العام نفسه ورغم استمرار وقف اطلاق النار
لا يزال الوضع السياسي للاقليم دون حل
فتره جمهوريه شبه رئاسيه غير معترف بها
لكنها مستقله بحكم الواقع
مولدوفا تتطلع من هذا المنتدى الى
الانضمام للاتحاد الاوروبي ربما كدرع واقي
من اي غزو محتمل من الدب الروسي بلال
البجداني العربيه
ومن قرب بلبوا من قرب العاصمه المولوديه
حسين قنيبر مدير مكتب العربيه في فرنسا
حسين اهلا بك معنا في التاسعه هذا المساء
لماذا عقدت قمه بهذا الحجم في بلد متواضع
الحضور والدور السياسي مولدوفا
مساء الخير نادين مولدوفا تتصدر لائحه
الدول الاكثر فقرا في اوروبا قال مصدر
رئاسي فرنسي ان اختيارها لعقد قمه
المجموعه السياسيه الاوروبيه التي كان
الرئيس ماكرون اطلق فكره انشائها قبل عام
يعودوا الى واقع رغبه الاوروبيين في ان
يرسلوا رساله قويه الى روسيا مفادها انهم
يقفون الى جانب هذا البلد الذي كان تعرض
لضغوط كبيره من جانب موسكو منذ اندلاع
الحرب في اوكرانيا مولدوفا طبعا كما ورد
في تقريركم تتضمن جيبا روسيا انفصاليا هو
هذا الجيب تبلغ مساحته 4000 كيلومتر مربع
عدد سكانه نصف مليون من ضمن عدد السكان
الاجمالي في مولدوفا وهو ثلاثه ملايين قد
تؤدي اي
احتكاكات في هذا الج الى انتقال الحرب الى
هنا الى مولدوفا الى هذا الجيب الانفصال
لتحديدا الواقع بين مولدافيا بين مولدوفا
واوكرانيا من هنا اختيار هذا البلد ليكون
مكانا الانعقاد قمه المجموعه السياسيه
الاوروبيه للتعبير عن الدعم الكامل له
اشاره لو سمحتي لي الى الجديد نادين سريعا
المتمثل ببيان مشترك صدر قبل قليل عن
الرئيسين الفرنسي والاوكراني بعد لقائهما
على هامش قمه مولدوفا جاء في هذا البيان
ان فرنسا ترغب في توسيع تدريب طيارين
عسكريين
السعودي امريكا ومن ثم اعود اليك في
حديثنا معك بيان سعودي امريكي السعوديه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه يعربان عن
قلقهما من انتهاكات الجسيمه لوقف النار في
السودان وايضا في البيان انهم قلقون من
انتهاكات الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع
لاعلان جده وايضا السعوديه وامريكا يعربان
عن قلقيمه اذا من الالتهابات الجسيمه لوقف
النار فهذه الانتهاكات كما اعرب البيان في
السودان اضرت بالمدنيين وايصال المساعدات
لهم ونذكر بان الجيش السوداني كان اعلن
وقف المفاوضات امام الجهود الامريكيه
والسعوديه
لجمع ممثلي الطرفي الصراع المسلحين في جده
للوصول الى هدنه طويله الامد وخلال هذا
اليوم كانت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
فرضت عقوبات على شركات تتبع لطرفي الصراع
المسلح كان هذا جديد الاخبار وفق بيان
السعودي الامريكي على كل حال نعود مره
اخرى الى موفدنا الى بلباكا وحسين قنيبر
يعود من جديد حسين تفضل واكمل فيما كنت
تتحدث عنه حول البيان الاخير
البيان الذي صدر عن الرئيسين الاوكراني
والفرنسي بعد لقائهما على هامش القمه هنا
في بول بواكا القريبه من
كيشيناو عاصمه جاء فيه ان فرنسا راغب في
توسيع تدريب طيارين عسكريين اوكرانيين
للمساهمه في حمايه المدنيين الاوكرانيين
من الضربات العسكريه الروسيه وبهذا الهدف
كلفه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني والفرنسي
بالتنسيق مع الولايات المتحده ومع دول
الراغبه في المشاركه في تدريب طيارين
عسكريين اوكرانيين كلفاء بوضع اليه ملموسه
لتحقيق هذا هدف اي توسيع تدريب طيارين
عسكريين على هامش هذه القمه التي تمحورت
حول الوضع في اوكرانيا عقدت ايضا عده
لقاءات جانبيه من بينها مثلا لقاء رعاه
الرئيس الفرنسي والمستشار الالماني بين
رئيس وزراء ارمينيا
والرئيس الاذربيجاني الهام علي كما التقى
الرئيس الفرنسي بكل من الرئيس الصربي
ورئيس اقليم كوسوفو واعلن ماكرون في مؤتمر
صحفي عقده مساء اليوم هنا ان المانيا
وفرنسا قدم تاه خطه لتهدئه التوترات بين
سلطات كوسوفو والجانب الصربي الصربي هناك
وان هذه الخطه متقدمه والمطلوب اليوم
تنفيذها ووصف ماكرون اصرار سلطات كوسوفو
على اجراء الانتخابات البلديه في المناطق
ذات الاكثريه الصربيه بانه كان خطوه مؤسفه
حسب تعبيره شكرا جزيلا لك حسين قنيبر موفد
العربيه الى
التاسعه هذا المساء مستمره ونتابع في
سياقها ولكن بعد قليل
الزواج على كتاب الله وسنه الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم وعلى المرض يسمى
بحضوري ملوك وامراء وقاده من حول العالم
الامير حسين ليعقد قرانه على الاميره رشوه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في تفاصيل التاسعه هذا المساء
اتهم القضاء العسكري اللبناني خمسه عناصر
من حزب الله احدهم موقوف اتهمهم بجرم
القتل العمدي في الاعتداء على دوريه
للكتيبه الايرلنديه العامله في قوه الامم
المتحده الموقفه في جنوب لبنان الهجوم
الذي وقع في الرابع عشر من ديسمبر تخلله
اطلاق رصاص على سياره مدرعه للكتيبه اثناء
مرورها في منطقه العقبيه ما اسفر عن مقتل
جنديا ايرلندي واصابه ثلاثه اخرين من
زملائه
هذا ورفعت اسرائيل حاله تاهب على الجبهه
الشماليه بشقيها السوري واللبناني بعد ان
حذر قاده الجيش والاجهزه الامنيه من امكان
اندلاع حرب مع حزب الله ومع ذلك يرى
مراقبون ان حظوظ ذلك تبقى منخفضه على كل
حال الزميل زياد حلبي جالا في المنطقه
الحدوديه الشماليه ووفانا بتقرير التالي
نتابع نحن هنا على الحدود الشماليه مع
لبنان بالتزامن مع مناورات عسكريه
اسرائيليه تحاكي اندلاء حرب متعدده
الجبهات فان الجيش الاسرائيلي يبقي على
حال تاهب قصوى على الجبهة الشماليه مع
لبنان وقد اخبر سكان البلدات والمستوطنات
الحدوديه بامكان ان تندلع حرب قريبا
وضروره اجلاء السكان منها رغم ان
المراقبين يستبعدون حدوث ذلك قريبا لكن
الجيش الاسرائيلي يواصل التدريبات
والتهديدات بامكان اندلاع مواجهه مع حزب
الله وهنا ايضا داخل مزارع شبعه المحتله
يسود التوتر شديد بين الجيشين الاسرائيلي
واللبناني بسبب حفر اسرائيل لخنادق في تلك
المنطقه لكن الصوره تبقى اعقد واكثر
تركيبا بكثير اسرائيل تتحرك وكان الحرب
على الابواب لانها تدعي بان ايران توشك
على اخفاء البرنامج النووي الايراني بعمق
كبير تحت الجبال بحيث يصبح منيعا وحصينا
امام الضربات حتى امام القنابل الذكيه
الخارقه للتحصينات الامريكيه ما يعني ان
هذه العمليه العسكريه يجب ان تكون سريعه
وعند التفكير بذلك يتم التفكير بامكان ان
تندلع حرب شامله على الجبهه الشماليه زياد
حلبي العربيه محيط مزارع شبح
[موسيقى]
بشق الانفس وقبل اربعه ايام من استحقاق
الديون تخطط صفقه بايدن هي عثرت مجلس
النواب فالاخير اقرت تشريع باغلبيه كبيره
شملت اصوات 314 نائبا وفيما عارضه 117
نائبا بينهم واحد وسبعون جمهوريا وبعد
اقراره في مجلس النواب تنتقل الكره الان
الى مجلس الشيوخ حيث الاغلبيه الديمقراطيه
وبعد موافقه الغرفتين ينشره بايدن كقنون
نافذ رئيس الامريكي اكد عدم حصول اي من
الطرفين على كل ما يريدونه بموجب الاتفاق
مشددا على ان الطريق الوحيد المضي قدما هو
تسويه بين الحزبين رئيس مجلس النواب
الجمهوري كامل مكارسي من جهه وصف اقرار
قانون المسؤوليه الماليه بخطوه اولى حاسمه
لاعاده بلاده الى المسار الصحيح مكارسي
اضافه ان مشروع القانون ينص على اكبر خفض
للمزريه في التاريخ الامريكي منتقدا ادمان
الانفاق في واشنطن المفاوضات الماراثونيه
اذا التي انتهت بشكل جيد وفقه بايد
ومكارثي لم تعجب الجمهوريين المحافظين
الذين انتقدوا عدم تامينها المزيد من
التخفيضات الجاده للانفاق كما شكك بعض
اعضاء الحزب الجمهوري في ملائمه مكارسي
للقياده مع تنازلاته الكثيره التي ادخلوها
خانه الخذلان
[موسيقى]
هي خطوه للوراء او على الاقل رجوع الى ما
خلف الكواليس ينوي الامير هاري وزوجته
ميجا اتخاذها فذوق وذوق قد تولي ادوار
بعيده عن انظار الجمهور اي التوقف عن
كتابه الكتب وصنع الافلام الوثائقيه
والجلوس لاجراء المقابلات لمهاجمه افراد
العائله المالكه مطلعون زعموا بان الخطوه
تاتي بعد فراغ جعبه الزوجين من اي شيء
ليقولوه فيما ردها اخرون لدخول يوم دائره
السخريه بلا هوادا فرغه الزوجين بالخصوصيه
تتناقض وفق صحف بريطانيه مع وجودهما
الدائم على منصات التلفزه وصنفتها
بمحاولات متكرره للفت النظر فيما عزت جهات
اخرى ابتعادهما عن الاضواء لصلح قد يلوح
بالافق بين هاري وعائلته يذكر ان ذوقه
وذوق عن الحياه في العائله المالكه قبل
ثلاث سنوات وهاجما خلالها باستمرار هذه
العائله سواء تلفزيونيا او في كتابه في
كتاب هاري سبير الذي من ضمنه ملابسات
وظروف تخليه عن واجباته الملكيه اذا دوق
وصف ايضا صمت عائلته تجاه الهجوم الاعلامي
عليه بالخيانه اياهم بتسريب خطته لانتقال
للعيش في الولايات المتحده اما عنصريه
العائله المالكه فكانت احدى شكاوى زوجته
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الصحفيه جوسلين اهلا بك معنا في التاسعه
هذا المساء مقابلات هنا وهناك جوسلين كتاب
صفير وايضا وثائقي على نتفليكس هل انتهت
بعد كل ذلك قصص وروايات هاري وميجن فلا
شيء يقولانه بعد الان ام فعلا يريدون ان
يرفعان علامه رايه البيضاء
هناك تشكيك كبير في الخبر المفاجئ الذي
نشرته صحيفه السن صحيفه السن ليست من
الصحف التي
يوثق باخبارها بالعاده فهي تعتمد على
الصحافه الصفراء نعم فهناك من يشكك بالخبر
بعينه لان الخبر جاء مفاجئا جدا فكما ذكرت
في البدايه قد يكون الخبر صحيحا بعدما راى
الامير هاري وزوجته ميجان بانه لا توجد
اخبار اخرى لكي يقولانها عن العائله
المالكه ولم تعد هناك فضائح اخرى يمكن ان
تضر الاموال عليهما وهناك من يقول من
المتابعين للشان الملكي في بريطانيا بان
الخبر قد يكون عاريا عن الصحه وانه نوع من
الادعايه الذاتيه للامير هاري وزوجته
طيب جوسلين يعني خلينا نفترض انه دائما ما
في دخان من دون نار زي ما بيقولوا ماذا لو
كان الامر صحيحا كيف ستتعامل العائله
المالكه مع هذه الاخبار
العائله المالكه كانت صامته وستبقى متبعه
هذا الاسلوب فالعائله المالكه الممثله
بالقصر الملكي
لا تعلق على هذه الاقاويل
بعد عرض المسلسل الطويل على نتفليكس وكل
الفضائح التي اطالت افراد بارزه في
العائله المالكه مثل الملك
الملك تشارلز والملكه كاملا وحتى ولي
العهد وزوجته لما يكن اي اي شيء يعني اي
رد من الناقبه العائله المالكه ولا اعتقد
بان هذه المره قد نشبع اي شيء
رسمي صادر عن العائله المالكه ولكن هناك
من يقول بان الامير هاري كان ينوي التنقل
ما بين المملكه المتحده وبين الولايات
المتحده وهذا ما دعاه الى اجراء يعني الى
الدخول في معركه قضائيه مع وزاره الداخليه
وهذه القضيه التي خسرها منذ حوالي
بعدما خسر القدره على الحمايه الذاتيه
التي طلبها من وزاره الداخليه فهو ينوي
العوده الى المملكه المتحده ولكن هذا
الامر سيكون من شبه المستحيلات خاصه وانه
لن يتنعم
بالحراسه الشخصيه على حساب
يعني دافعي الضرائب في البلاد
الاسره الحاكمه الملكيه لطالما غرقت
بالفضائح والازمات والعائليه ولكنها
تجاوزتها هل ستطوى هذه الصفحه نهائيا
باختصار
قد تطوى هذه الصفحه ولكن
لا توجد يعني اي مؤشرات في الافق القريب
وهذا ما شاهدناه يعني في حفل التتويج
عندما حضر الامير هاري فلم يتم اي نوع من
تصفيه الحسابات او يعني من عوده المياه
الى مجاريها في حفل كبير جدا ربما كانت
فرصه للامير هاري للعوده الى كنف العائله
ولكن هذا الشيء لم يحصل شكرا جزيلا لك من
لندن الصحفيه جوسلين ايليا شكرا
[موسيقى]
اعلنت ديوان الملكي الاردني عن منح الانسه
رجوى السيف لقب الاميره رجوى الحسين وذلك
بعد عقد قرانها على ولي عهد الاردن الامير
حسين بن عبد الله الثاني شهدت مراسم عقد
القران في قصر زهران بالعاصمه عمان حضور
قاده وزعماء دول وضيوف من كافه انحاء
العالم
بنفس على كتاب الله وسنه رسوله صلى الله
عليه وسلم
[موسيقى]
وفي نهايه التاسعه هذا المساء لم يبقى الا
نذكر بالعناوين
لعدم التزامهما بالهدنه واشنطن تعاقب
شركات تابعه للجيش السوداني والدعم السريع
وتلوح بالمزيد
زعيما صربيا يساعدان الازمه بين بلديهما
وتحرك غربي لمنع الحرب بينهما
لاول مره منذ الحرب الاوكرانيه روسيا تصده
هجوما بالدبابات على بيلجرود الحدوديه
هاري وميجن يتراجعان خطوه للوراء ويعتزمان
التوقف عن انتقاد العائله المالكه عبر
الاعلام
التاسعه هذا المساء انتهت ولكن اخبرنا
بالتاكيد مستمره بعد قليل الزميل طاهر
بركه و360 ساعه اخباريه مختلفه معك يا
طاهر يسعد مساك ومساك نادين شكرا جزيلا
طبعا سنفتح ملف السودان بقوه هذه الليله
مع تعليق السعوديه والولايات المتحده
المفاوضات بين طرفي الازمه بسبب عدم جديه
الطرفين حتى عودتهما الى التزام الجديه
ونفتح ايضا ملف الهجوم البري الاوكراني
فيرود الروسيه اضافه الى متابعه عقد
القران الملكي في الاردن ارجو ان تكوني
معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات